I'm Dan Abrams and we are on Patrol live
with eight departments around the
country including the Richland County
Sheriff's Department in South Carolina
where Captain Danny Brown and master
Deputy Addie Perez are in pursuit of a
fleeing motorcycle
we have a few units chasing a few dirt
bikes I believe they got one or two at
this point they're they popped around
right now and they're coming towards me
Captain Brown so apprecially the catch
up on them
[Music]
where they're coming back towards us now
so we're gonna try to get up ahead of
them and just see if we can help them
get these guys stopped
We're not gonna be able to spike strip
them because they're bites but they've
got one guy they're chasing Now traffic
but there's a neighborhood up here that
we've been having issues with the dirt
bikes that's probably where he's headed
to and if we get into that neighborhood
maybe we're getting caught all right
we stood up a little bit because they're
coming straight towards us now uh on the
Side Road
46.
I'm trying to be smart about it and safe
about it if we can get them to see all
these lights
or pork
knowing your area
straight this way now
they're just about half mile from us it
sounds like
it
is
we'll get out here just pretend that
we've got this intersection
all right we're at Fair on hard
scrolling should be coming from our
right right here
search way to go
he's about 53
Street
next thing but he's probably not enough
[Music]
thank you
going out bathroom
he's gonna come this way
almost guaranteed he's gonna come this
way
I'm just gonna see if I can sit here and
make him think that we got spikes out
[Music]
all right
so we're right now behind the individual
that's on the dirt bike
and we're trying to intercept it right
now
we just got up to the suspect he's right
up there in a white shirt high traffic
speeds about 60. barely see the dirt
bike it's actually no lights on it
it's going towards Clemson
he's trying to get back here for some
reason
yeah he's hard to see right now
[Music]
I made it right a long time
Long Town Road right on Long tone Road
[Music]
between about 65. you still got him
do I have um
I can call it for you
I don't need to be advised yesterday
moving
[Music]
all right he's right there
[Music]
the elementary school again
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody else
get a good intersection points at all
those intersections for me please
[Music]
Consulting description white T-shirt
black helmet lawn dreads black jeans
dark jeans with white sneakers
[Music]
travel now for directions
[Music]
don't Hard Scrabble still Hard Scrabble
I got you
hard to travel past
e hold on
yeah
[Music]
10 50 10 50 10 50.
don't move don't move don't move don't
move don't move turn around turn around
turn around turn around
Central Center 52 Center 52.
the suspect just hit the vehicle
gonna be on Elders Pond Drive hard
scrubber Road it's gonna be lacerations
on the left arms
don't move
forward
are you crazy look what you just did to
yourself do not move do not move because
at this point in time it's take the time
to take care of you you understand we're
not we're not doing all this right now I
need
because now we got to take care of what
just happened to you okay
just relax
we need to do this first
we will in a second we just need to do
this first all right just relax are you
feeling dizzy or anything like that
right now I'm good tell me the truth I
promise you need to tell me the truth I
promise you I'm good can you hit your
head no no can I just call my brother
come out here
okay so don't move
relax
relax
EMS know there's going to be two
ambulances needed we got a approximately
two years welcome to on Patrol live
we've got more than 50 cameras across
the country following law enforcement in
real time joining me in the studio
formerly of the Tulsa Police Department
Sergeant Sean sticks Larkin and from the
Richland County Sheriff's Department
which we've been watching Deputy Curtis
Wilson let's go right back out uh to
master Deputy Addie Perez who is tending
to that guy who just took a big hit out
there
you're doing it on purpose
you're right yeah he said you're scared
about police you know I'm getting hurt
and getting killed but you're the one
almost killed yourself
moving your arm you need to stop moving
your arm you're doing all that movement
is not just lay your arm down just lay
your arm down all right
I know I'm just trying to hold you up so
you don't hit your head on the ground
right now
all right I'm good I'm going I'm good
I'm good I'm good I'm good I know we're
gonna help you out relax
ation before the green dirt bike please
let them know your green certain plate
no no
just put your arms just put your arm
down can you pull up pull what my finger
no no you crazy
you don't lost your mind I think you're
gonna start pulling and popping right
now it
don't do that like you're doing too much
you're doing too much
just chill out we gotta ambulance I was
uh quite an incident there and again
shows why police have to be very careful
in pursuing a motorcycle dirt bike Etc
in your department they tend to show
great care in that absolutely and you
know sometimes they do call them off
because of that fact and as you know in
the state of South Carolina there's no
helmet law but if you're 21 and older
younger then you have to have one but 21
and Over
no luck yeah you know the the pursuit
policies vary from from Department to
Department even within the same state uh
places like Tulsa we will not Chase
anybody on a motorcycle any longer
unless we know it's a felony um and even
then it's still evaluated is it a
violent felony is it you know is it a
larceny or is this guy wanted for
robbery because of the danger for the
the suspect actually yeah and also uh
danger for other people involved there
there may have been uh some injuries in
the car as well which we will continue
to cover uh throughout this program